[Music]
this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
hello everyone and a very warm come to a
sunset driver we are in the Mara Trang
with Kenya and we have that beautiful
tree out in this savanna well my name is
David that has not changed and with me
in cameras bunga bunga good afternoon
so this come up so camera men always
confuse me sometimes they do that
sometimes they do that sometimes they do
that and the only one out understand is
one gentleman South Africa's Senzo
because since we used to this man that
when I asks invite that hit on me
he got three daughters and I think about
triplets in how welcome to the morrow
triangle and it's not a warm day but a
hot day I do not know whether you can
see a bit of shimmering from where we
are as we show you the savanna it is 88
degrees Fahrenheit and for those who
love during the metric system 31 degrees
centigrade that's to me by any standard
it is too hot and if that doesn't sound
very good for me because I would guess
most of the cuts unlike the big animals
could be lazing somewhere in shade until
take cools off
remember we usually come to live in
direct and we always request you to ask
us as many questions as you can
should you have any nice comments like
saying wow that's beautiful Savannah
please do send them through hashtag
sapphire life on Twitter and I think
I've done very well in terms of
housekeeping and I just want you to
enjoy that view of what I would call the
Mara savanna of the Mara Triangle in
Kenya exactly and yeah I mean the final
control says this one is one landscape
that you'll not or it cannot be matched
by anybody else when we will go to Juma
you will notice always the vegetation is
very different and awestruck
King - boom Gary the other day telling
him I think with a good brain oculus is
here in the Mara you can see an elephant
10 kilometers away you know which is
very possible but well in Juma it's very
tricky boots here
an elephant 100 meters away you'll
always be very very lucky
no you notice how tall the grass is and
that tall grass you see is called the
red red or grass and it will get taller
and taller until the wildebeest will
come to mow it down in the next maybe
six or seven months or thereabout well
out here in African wilderness I'm not
the only one and there's a beautiful
girl by the name of Jamie who would like
to say maybe something like a jumbo
jumbo to all of you David might be able
to see across ten kilometers on a nice
clear day in the Maasai Mara I drove
past these wild dogs the first time I
have to turn around and come and
double-check the area before we finally
spotted them but spot that we did a very
good afternoon to all of you my name is
Jamie this afternoon as Sebastian is on
camera with me and he didn't see them
either first time we drove faster was
really very very embarrassing we're
coming to you live from Juma private
game reserve which is in the greater
Kruger National Park area of South
Africa right here's what everybody needs
to do we need to all hope like absolute
crazy that these doggies decide to stick
around and stay on Juma right up until
half past seven at which point they can
if they wish depart but and up and until
that moment they absolutely have to stay
here preferably not in that tree though
they are hidden beneath a such dense
vegetation that they are almost
impossible to see and I suppose I should
call them in on the game drive radio I
haven't yet but I'll get to that in a
little but we've only just found them we
owe Ally Holly and Lauren and trishula
this particular wild dog sighting as
they were out earlier scouting about
for animals and they came upon these
wild dogs and one of them actually
barked at them because they were looking
for their tracks to try and figure out
where they went on foot there we go we
have our collection of incredibly flat
incredibly well hidden wild dogs to keep
us entertained and the thing is is that
Sebben are not going anywhere
emesis this we know at least their
breathing given how much dust they have
on their noses yes they're all
definitely breathing and panting away
quite happily it is muggy Seb you're
right I know I was I was wondering I
said for saying it was so warm and we
had to drive a bit but actually it is
really muggy sweaty whether it's not
that hot I don't think Jim is that hot
today but it is very very humid I assume
it's the same pack that Tristan had this
morning in fact I'm not even going to
say I assume I know it is the same pack
as wild dogs at Tristan head this
morning which would make it I assume the
Ambala pack is what I was actually going
to say all the interesting breakaways we
probably I imagine will not be calling
them the investing breakaways tonight on
sov c3 look at those enormous ears
I know spoilt dogs twice in a day we're
hoping for other things as well we've
been seven I won the lucky draw here the
dogs are the only animals that we know
of that have been found so far today and
we got sent here immediately because
we've got the special thermal camera
we've got the FLIR so we're feeling
thoroughly spoiled we we drew the long
straw we got very lucky it does make
sense of the thermal camera though in
case they decide to vanish into the
darkness which is going to be almost
impossible for us to keep up right now
it's very hard to imagine these dogs
racing around but they absolutely do I
promise
well speaking of someone who presumably
isn't racing around quite as fast as
wild dog off you pop to James so he can
say hello
now I'm not racing around I'm placed on
a Sunday
hello everybody welcome to the Sunday
afternoon Sunday Safari sunset Safari I
don't know why I have to say it like
that but we are on there's an ax men
would have did you see it David
it looks like an emerald spotted wood
dove but with a very long tail sorry
everyone welcome to the scene of the
sunset Safari Marvis that all with us we
are on our way down the Henry Ford's
bonanza see if we can find hasanah or
some other form of spotted cat there it
is you see it flying there everybody I'm
just gonna mmm it's flown over the road
no Mac would've definitely looks like an
animal spotted would Duff stand by one
I'll find your picture please ask us any
questions you'd like to using the
hashtags fire live on Twitter otherwise
of course the YouTube chat stream will
work just as effectively you might get
lost in the chatter so I'd suggest
Twitter you know certainly in the first
part of the drive because what will
happen in the beginning of the drive is
I'll get back to your thoughts just been
said to me and because of course all of
you are greeting each other currently on
the chat which means that any biological
query is lost in amongst all of you
saying hello to each other which is very
friendly of course but possibly not the
best for questions and I'm not saying
you should stop saying hillier to each
other it's very nice to see right the
Namaqua dove is this fellow here number
five and you can see it looks a little
bit like nimble spotted wood dove it's
got little purplish spots actually
didn't realize that and the longtail
that's definitely what we had but
interestingly there are much more common
in drier areas than they are in these
hesitate to call this a wet area would
you expect them to find them in the dry
areas of the Kruger
and that doesn't really bode well
because of course it means that
everything's dried then I've just been
asked by Tristan to say paulie's name in
the in a cockney accent well I'll do it
in a cockney accent so cockney accent
I'll just need to lead up to it a little
bit I don't think we're gonna say cold
early to die oh I know where he is I
think he's sitting in his room Paulie
that will be in a cockney accent the
accent I was doing however before that
was North Country and I can do it in a
North Country accent as well ah say look
at that there's Paulie is going out
hunting for animals today I heard
another wonderful little skit did I do
this no just do this for you David I
didn't do it for anyone else a skit on
on the interwebs the other day of two of
the Game of Thrones actresses doing the
first few lines of Hakuna Matata in that
sort of North Country accent that their
use in Game of Thrones so
arias fallen down they didn't hook him a
father-like doesn't have n something
like this
Hakuna Matata one is Hakuna Matata
it is nor passing phrase
we didn't go through a dip Emma David
who is on camera today but may as well
be asleep let the aerial fall down we
are we got nah David
so should I do it again Emma Hakuna
Matata what a wonderful phrase Hakuna
Matata ain't no passing craze
me too I'm also waiting for the casting
calls thank you very much Emma Emma says
she's waiting for the casting calls to
come in I think I would be welcome Game
of Thrones
thinking what Papa Peck is I think that
flu season has cleaned I wanna wait my
friend rings costing Kalev don't think
yes yes I'd love to
I think I'd like a butterfly yeah yes I
have an unfortunate lack of skill in the
accent Department or at the very least I
can't off the top of my head imitate an
accent but then what happens to me is as
soon as I'm talking to someone who has a
strong accent from wherever it happens
to be completely unintentionally and
without you know without even thinking
about it so completely subconsciously I
start to speak back to them in their
accent which leads to a great amount of
misunderstanding because of course they
think I'm mocking them and they become
quite offended and that's happened to me
quite a few times in my life where I've
been speaking to someone from Scotland
or Ireland or Australia or America and I
start to imitate the accent and I don't
know why I do it and I can't help myself
it's not intentional but I cannot it's
very uncomfortable incredibly
uncomfortable feeling when all of a
sudden you realize that you sound as
though you parodying them unfortunately
heavier my South African accent gets
these days because of course I live in
the low felt the less that seems to
happen to me because the South African
accent is one that well and truly
entrenches itself upon your soul it's
also the hardest one to imitate I don't
know many people who can imitate two
South African accent well and because
naturally there's the the typical
rivalry of various countries we get
quite insulted if someone mistakes us
for an Australian or New Zealander
no mind too much if we're mistaken
frozen Bob Wian or botswana botswana
ioan that's one
oh cool that's funny and I don't think I
mean I'm really just babbling at you
because right now at this exact point
there is nothing I can do to improve
your view of the dogs and they are very
very much asleep oh if we imagine all of
the animals speaking in different
accents it'll becomes even more
hilarious wild dogs would speak with a
hmm I could get myself into trouble for
doing this I'm thinking the same I feel
as though a wild dog new pods definitely
have a French accent and savor the bad
guys really oh well yes I suppose if we
if we stick to if we stick to sell
African accents no I don't think wild
dogs would ever sent in Johannesburg
accent I think they'd know they're not
laid-back enough for a cab Tony an
accent definitely not a cap toe knee and
hip stacks and mm-hmm no maybe Em's
right here one of those high-powered
businessman in Joburg hmm no it doesn't
fit either Italian hi good I could see
it
um you see I'm haunted accent Oh Mamma
Mia I
I was listening I would say guava via
repeatedly the wild dogs something about
it basic pack I think he'd probably been
asking why they would call the investing
pack their breakaways from the original
mystic but the right I got it
alex is discussing accents alex is that
that's why they called the investig--
back if they happen to have proper
Joburg high-powered accents maybe it
wasn't dust on their noses
it was a bit of leaf Daniel says that he
loves the Italian accent I yes indeed I
think it works
I think saves right I think Italian
works quite well of course alex is in FC
now I'm wondering what animal would have
a Russian accent hmm cheetah Rosita
maybe not
you see it's ridiculous because we're
talking about all African animals which
of course doesn't quite work I have no
idea and I have no idea if anyone else
is following along with my trains of
thought this afternoon well if you go
across to Tristan who's presumably a
great deal more sensible than I am
well I don't know if that's probably the
case Jamie in any way whatsoever as
sensible between the three of us is
probably not really going to happen but
Reid in this conversation and I can't
believe Jamie forgot which animals would
have a Russian accent it's quite obvious
Rayleigh that it would be Boris the
blade and Vladimir from Chitra damn they
would both have a Russian accent
crocodiles would make a perfect Russian
mobster I would be the right kind of
animals for the Russian accent and as
for the wild dogs I think they would
have a I think a really good one would
be a English soccer hooligan accent
which is I don't really know what
exactly a soccer hooligan accent is but
that's what I think that they would have
and they run around just causing havoc
wherever they go that's how I feel about
the wild dogs but this accent story is
quite funny we often we often go is kind
of notions as to what accents certain
animals would have hello Dorfman goose
are you one of the ones that survived
Columba I'm just gonna see if there's
any others doesn't see live in fact
there is any others at all at the moment
probably a good opportunity for me to us
to say hello properly my name is Justin
on camera I've got BK this afternoon
here we go sir BK is once again Arts in
about and hopefully he's going to bring
us more luck it seems Becca is the lucky
charm for all of us at the moment
because BK in the last 24 hours has seen
a honey badger he has seen two leopards
in a sighting one stealing a kill from
another he has seen wild dogs this
morning he and what else have you had
lots of ILI's all kinds of things so BK
is now the new lucky charm and that's
why I've I've stolen him for the
afternoon Safari and I'm going to make
sure that he brings us luck for this
afternoon
I certainly going to need it so we're
going to head off towards tortured and
we're going to need luck for one signal
to for a leopard and 2/3 to be able to
get a leopard in a signal area on
tortured so that's why we need big guys
like assassin it's a tall ass but we
shall try and endeavor to bring a some
sort of spotty rosy cat to you guys now
what is interesting
is that last night I got an update today
about this last night the guys said that
on their way home somebody in coral guys
on their way at home which would have
been its baths just about ten to seven
quarter to seven they said they got that
skittish big male leopard coming out
from the mullah Watty twin dams area
going towards baboon pad when they said
that he was celebrating quite heavily so
I don't know what he was up to and what
he's doing inside Zuma but I fear that
he is starting to make more and more of
a push the more leptin Ghana has not
really been hanging around that side so
it's not ideal we need to garner to go
back down that way and push the skittish
male back where he's come from because
we do not need a skittish male leopard
around or certainly not too skittish
that's what he is you know who come on
he was one thing because our community
would at least allow you to find him and
then you'd kind of move off this male
seems to be an absolute ghost during the
day and the guys were telling me last
night and when they found him as soon as
the second car arrived he was gotten in
a second so one car you see apparently
was okay at night and with the spotlight
but as soon as the second car arrived he
you didn't want anything to do with
anyone and moved off and so I wonder how
far he's pushing into Juma these days
and whether or not the tracks that we're
seeing a lot of the time actually for
him or if therefore you know Hassan oh
or Tinga know who Camry it's an
interesting kind of Ben's turn of events
that's taking place and it's certainly
gonna be an interesting winter if this
carries on the other bit of news that I
do have from Nicole Gauri is that the
den sites on little Gauri is active once
again so Corky and pretty hostile at the
Dane sites on the Qatari and it is still
active so that's where they are at the
moment
and they seemingly everybody is doing
fine apparently they've all the little
ones are still there now em if you can
just repeat the name for me sorry I
caught the question but I didn't catch
the name I was too busy talking as per
normal which happens a lot when it's
with me unfortunately Becky so Becky and
Tigana hasn't really been sowing no and
he hasn't really although you know last
night he looked good he didn't saw
because he was too busy trying to feed
his face once more and and going into
full sausage mode and so he chased sandy
off and then what I well why we gonna
hit torture at his party to go and see
where the two of them ended up going no
one actually checked that area this
morning
with the wild dogs and Columba and there
was lions on before so everyone kind of
was busy with those things so we're
gonna go and check that area quite
carefully and we're gonna hope that
we're gonna be able to pick up tracks
for where the two of them went if they
followed one another if they split
whatever the case may be but that's what
we're going to go and try and see and
try and figure out where they've gone
whose tracks for a lipid here but these
have been driven over so that's for a
female leopard probably or more likely
than Tandy from a few days ago and the
other sort of bit of news that I have is
also the Inca homers are miles away so
they're all the way in Robson's which is
north of singita so there are a long
long way away hopefully they'll come
back fairly soon anyway talking about
lines
it sounds like David is on the search
for the sausage tree pride and hopefully
he'll have some luck this afternoon well
I don't think I need to talk about the
accents and it took about the taste
because what I'm looking for is this
sausage tree pride so I'm talking abouts
tests so you can change the topic a
bitch and from accents let's talk about
the tests of this animals when when each
one of they say the cuts they each
different you know different different
three when they hunt for example Impala
to Thompson gazelles
to waterboxx to zebras what tests do
they ever get the test I mean I would
want to have a little discussion with
Jamie and James and Christian and
finding out do this almost tell the
difference now I'm assuming elastic
lions for example lions have been known
to hunt wildebeest zebras he learns
giraffes buffaloes and especially the
price that I'm looking for where I am
this is a cheap ride and I won't know
when they eat
all right I just continue that might be
topical a tell is for James who could be
having a very interesting
hello everybody here we have got a mob
build duck I know that's not its real
name anymore it is now the comb duck but
I just like the term novel build because
well it doesn't look like it's got a
comb does it David it looks like it's
got a very large knob on its head and it
is waddling slowly towards us with its
knob
and for once the missus is following the
the male and not the other way around
see them eating grass seeds that's quite
cool I was going to have to look up what
they eat but I'm going to tell you now
they eat grass seeds
sorry Lily you say have we seen one of
these before yes we have absolutely seen
one of these before Lily Jamie found
this novel duck in this very pond I
think it was about five days ago or so I
think so yes we've seen this very
individual and we've seen his wife and
two of them are very much enjoying a
little bit of it looks like signal grass
to me there's some cloris actually isn't
that cool doesn't dissociate seed-eating
with lava build ducks who will need any
kind of duck let me have a look and see
if they eat anything else deathful duck
here we go now it is in fact called the
nob bill duck still that's nice
well let's have a look I don't know
Cathy what is the knob made of I suspect
it's because they lose it outside of
breeding season so our suspect it's put
some kind of skin let's have a look
adult male breeding crown center of
hypnic Upper blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah bill black with
large laterally complete compressed
fleshy comb or nob on the upper mandible
and prominent nail so it's basically
fleshy so I think it's kind of a soft
fleshy thing that grows there each
season it is much reduced outside of the
breeding season let's see what it eats
it has been recorded eating of the
following oh this is quite interesting
the breeding male has a feeding or
loafing territory with variable boundary
in which he feeds with his mate and
sometimes with unmated females dirty
fellow
breeding birds may dabble in the muddled
stripped grass seeds while waiting in
shallow water females probably dabble
more than males to breeding males blah
blah blah fish paste fish post mm-hmm
right so they've been recorded eating
largely grass seeds actually and then
sometimes water lilies yeah cross seeds
that's their that's their that's their
vibe
and just gave a long list of the kinds
of grass seeds they like
Rosalind no I don't think there are many
noble ducks and juma at all because this
is the only one I've seen and in fact
this mobile duck is not in fact in June
at all he is in fact in little Gauri
which is unfortunate strange place room
to have chosen to use David when you
come bring the camera back to me you
need to make a clicking sound so that I
know all right no you didn't I see you
didn't want them to hear it seated
quietly anyway I'm sorry you got a view
of the back of my head David's fault
it's a press-on novel duck we have a
lovely sighting here of a white Ford
Ranger with a ladder on the back very
good
it's very nice relaxed to mobile to dark
msn
all right I believe that David was mid
conversation when we found the novel
duck so let's go back across to him to
find out what it was he was going to say
well I got interrupted by that feathered
friend of James Holley ah who Jesus
always interesting because the time is
you catch a bat and put it on the frame
then she goes away now
I decided we changed the topic from the
accents of animals you know and we do
something different and we do tests of
the Predators I'm talking about China's
lions cheetahs leopards wall dogs like
what Jimmy Hoffa and the way I want us
to look at this is for example say
afraid like what I'm looking for the
such a cheap ride has about five females
to males in the capture of youngsters
now should they catch or maybe should
grab it three of those girls catch I say
a zebra maybe late in evening and then
you shall have the other Lions coming in
the darkness so if the rest of them
joined the party or join the dinner once
already dark do they know all the Lions
always tell what's the issue of course
it's meat of course it is proteins so
what at once asterisk us is the Lions
that come at Saturn or assume you
blindfold them and they just come and
they start digging in and eating
whatever was hunted before I mean do the
cuts or do the hyenas or other predators
across the board do they know what type
of media eating I mean they got tests
but I guess I wash all this but I'd
imagine just like us human beings
they're predators good taste buds on
their tongues so can they tell meat of a
zebra from well wish of this animal from
the other and personally I am very bad
in that the only mythic until a hundred
percent it is pork we made pork I know
it spoke there are some times I'll eat
lamb and gods we have what you call God
see in Africa and I'll always ask the
chef
what what's meat are we eating and then
we got a chair from the Camco David like
me and he lost tell me don't be selling
what do you think you're eating I mean I
have no idea
I know it is meat
and he tells me keep hitting and ask him
how do I know what I'm eating and he
says it's very chewy
when spife it's very soft it's LOM which
doesn't make sense to me anyway
Brent you're talking of what you think
it's a Matisse if it's like sugar I
think you got a point I think you got a
point what you need to do branch now is
to put Jamie Tristan and James and ask
them either one if they know and if they
do how how can we help maybe the viewers
tell but when a lion is eating say a
zebra this is the way to eat and maybe
the disability behaves when a lion is in
a buffalo this is the way it behaves I
think it is sounds rather a stupid topic
a stupid topic but I think it's always
good to maybe ask ourselves I mean do
predators know what media eating if they
get meat in the darkness they find other
family members it's in the same are they
like well we had a zebra yesterday and
we have zebra gain trip you know a
better choice we'll keep eating it and
how I'm sure I'm giving them a lot of
pressure but I am in the area that they
called the sausage republic which is
this one I was here yesterday for three
hours and I got a bit frustrated because
I never saw them and let's find out what
Jamie will say because she got wild dogs
well dogs are very good successful
hunters now see what Jim Jim will say in
terms of wild dogs testing the meat all
right perhaps I would say that there's
probably some really fundamental
differences between the way that the
wild dogs behave here in Juma as opposed
to in the Maasai Mara it's such a
different hunting habitat that it really
is almost
incomparable for an animal that hunts in
the way that the wild dogs do here and
Juma they they're not animal they don't
chase down animals to the point of exist
Austan in the way that people always
believe that wild dogs did with one pack
member overtaking another when the pack
member got tired it doesn't work like
that here
there's no vast open stretches of land
where they go sprinting off after prey
and I don't think that the Dwyer dogs
deliberately select anything to be
honest I think obviously the Impala form
the main part of their diet
because there are so many Impala in
parlor and scrub hares and that's just
because that those are the animals that
they encounter the most but I don't
think their behavior really changes they
just get up and they run and they trot
and they see something and they run at
it and they create panic and chaos in
thick vegetation because they're so
agile and so quick and they are able to
pick out an individual and eventually
manage to catch it so I don't think
there's any differences in behavior in
terms of the diet that they follow
they've been recorded to even hunt baby
Buffalo are obviously it also depends on
pack size if a baby if a buffalo herd
went running past a pack of four wild
dogs there would be absolutely no chance
I would say that they even going to
attempt something that large where if
you've got say the Hamiltons pack of
eighteen wild dogs well then that would
probably make a difference to their prey
selection but mostly is opportunistic
now there we go child of the universe is
wandering from that if wild dog packs in
the juma and the Mara are of different
sizes not to the best of my knowledge
wild dog packs can be highly variable in
size it also of course depends on their
success when it comes to that year's
litter of Cubs but coming pups
comes from pups because of course the
female can have loads of pups at one go
she can have ten she can have more than
ten pups and if they manage to keep them
alive obviously that's a massive boost
to their numbers so while dog pack
numbers grow and shrink quite rapidly
then you get your dispersal packs as
well so it really it I don't think that
there is much difference to the best
obviously I have never once seen a wild
dog in the Mara
I know that they have been seen live
twice but I certainly didn't see one
while I was there so as far as I'm aware
no there's no real difference between
the pack sizes of the Mara
or on Juma or if there is it's an on
average the difference of one or two
dogs
I would guess I can't see you know
having that many that many individuals
is always a cutoff point the same goes
for lion prides you have too many
individuals in a social group of
predators there's never it might help
with hunting but it also doesn't really
give them much in the way of an
advantage of food or access to food
because all of a sudden there's more
mouths to feed
where hyenas are a little bit different
the massive clans of hyenas in the Mara
make complete sense because of the way
that they work up there both in terms of
tackling predators bigger predators like
lions but also because a hyena clan
isn't always together you know you don't
find one group of 80 hyenas all together
unless perhaps they're in the middle of
a disagreement over territory during a
clan war or perhaps maybe at a caucus
but mostly hyena clans are split up
usually the high rancors hang out with
the high rancors and maybe some males
and sometimes the low rankers hang out
with each other but they don't stay
together in the same way that a wild dog
Packer stays so there are so so tightly
bonded you'd be hard-pressed to find a
more tightly bonded group of social
carnivores except perhaps maybe lions
but of course a completely different
social structure now just for those of
you that don't know perhaps you've only
recently discovered to the life safaris
because we do get new viewers every now
and again on each and every Safari you
get your beautiful white legs you're not
looking at a feral dog this is not some
mutt some mongrel that has wandered in
off the streets this is a completely
different species of completely
different genus actually to the dogs
that we know
of course as it does this completely
doglike pose and looks exactly like a
little doggie that you could go up and
rub its belly these are wild animals of
a completely different genus there are
sort of our equivalent of wolves they're
quite a lot smaller and they obviously
don't live in snow although now have
been found up in the snowy mountain tops
in Kilimanjaro I love this one's tail
it's got the coolest tail it keeps
flicking it and I keep missing it it's
got a little black arrow on the on its
tail right in the middle of the white
patch it's really cool but of course
every time I try and draw attention to
it it puts it back down again so what
you're dealing with is actually Africa's
second most endangered big carnival big
predator there are hardly any left so
this is something really really special
and although we don't have the best view
at the moment and although they're not
doing very much every moment with these
animals is precious because they are
constantly running along the knife edge
of extinction because once you lose a
certain number of certain species that
comeback is almost impossible right now
they're treating that very very fine
line this pack of course has no idea
that that is the case hey puppies I just
know I'm looking at your faces and I
just know that you are going to get up
and go running off dreama just looking
at you I know it look at that dog it's
got mischief written all over its sleepy
sleepy sleepy face while I wait the
business to do that hopefully it Tristan
is having some luck I know he's been in
search of lipids let's find out how
that's going
well good luck Jamie with the dogs
hopefully they do get up to no good and
hopefully they run deep into Juma where
we are at the moment is exactly where
Ali lifts the llama this morning and so
we're in the right sort of place for
where she could be unjust quickly he's
just scanning underneath every single
tree at the moment in the hope that we
can maybe spot oh just sleeping it got
quite warm after Ali left her so I'm
hoping that she eventually fell asleep
it seemed like she was kind of never
going to sleep she kind of kept drooping
off and then all of a sudden would poppy
but walking so I'm gonna try and see if
we can find her
Ali and set both said to me that she was
still moving so I mean the chances of
her is still being here is very slim but
it's worth us just double checking and
having a little bit of a look around she
might have just found herself a nice
comfy spot to lie down so that's what
we're looking for is anyway when it's a
bit of shade and maybe a nice little
termite mound with some shade on top of
it and those are all good places for a
little Leopard yeah
that's also in a tree and Columba is not
that scared of sitting up in trees by
herself
and so we're just having a little look
around in the hope that we can spot her
in one of these kind of big marilla's or
something like that but it's gonna be
tricky I mean it's this is probably one
of the biggest blocks on tortured and so
finding her in this is really not gonna
be easy
what now lots of you are saying you
think that she would be great for TV I
agree with you I think she's always
going to be good quality for TV I just
wanna see
I wonder what that is there's a marina
tree over there with the big bump in it
I don't think it's a leopard but let me
just double-check and make sure they're
not so leopard it is just the way the
branch turns it looks as though there
might be something sleeping it's against
the light so I can't see color now I'm
colors always your friend when you see
things in trees because leopards often
appear a lot lighter than the foliage
around them so that's why I was just
having a little look now this termite
mound would be a good place to look
except that it's quite sort of sunny
here so not ideal for a little lipid
like the lumber to spend too much time
in a sunny spot like that so we're gonna
just try and check more the shady areas
there's some really nice big trees here
and to my right and so one of these
trees will be probably a good place to
check underneath them or somewhere close
she suppose could want to go for water
which means that we if we find the
nearest what's a point which I think
would be Torchwood Dam the thing you say
that branch is close to my head
yes well there's been a few these last
few days and maybe it'll knock some
sense into me and knock some ability to
find a lipid into me again because we've
been struggling a little bit with
finding our spotty cats but one learns
very quickly how to dodge branches Rin
driving around in places like this I
don't see her anyway here I'm not sure
we're going to find her yeah I think
what the base plan is now is maybe just
to go back onto the roads and just check
she hasn't come out of here she hasn't
come out of here well then the next base
plan is to be on foot for a while and
maybe just listen for some alarm calls
or something like that but I want to
just check this grove of trees in my
over here because her general direction
was kind of coming to where I am now and
so this will be a good spot to check
around the problem is is that the grass
is so long that it's really tricky to
see anything I mean we're gonna have to
literally drive right on top of her
we go into spotter I'm afraid unless
she's up and elevated all right well
let's keep trying let's see what we get
you never know good things can come to
those who try and so in the mean time up
to David who's also trying to find the
cats that he's looking for this
afternoon
well Kristen how to tell you this is one
of my many afternoons where I have God's
almost thinking almost trying to say I'm
a little bit frustrated by this
afternoon because all the animals are
always have hoped to have seen by now
they almost all over but I think I have
so much love for the substitute trip
ride that I tend forget that the other
animals count and then engage teasing me
and he's telling me it's because I did
not go to church and I did not know
today is a Sunday until he told me well
I've decided to take a different
direction and temporarily forget about
the sausages sausages it's a print of
lions that live around this place and
it's my favorite price so I've said that
I'll forget about it fast look for
something else and maybe in the process
of looking for something else I might
bump into them so I'm looking for
anything big anything small and more so
something big possibly if I'm lucky
looking even for elephants or for
giraffes and it all depends on the luck
that I will have with myself it's just a
truck hood carry in front of me
I just want very quickly with them and
then tell them good luck so just give me
two seconds I want to find out if
there's something very interesting you
come and asuka you
running it well we've you're lucky this
could be the day and my friends are
telling me they're equally frustrated
like me so those Cubs
gerrae I'd be more than happy we see
them now this that's one female we think
she's the new West's mother Kings tell
because she gonna do not turn her child
she has the nearest mother and all of us
all of us are trying to see her cubs
because they'll be the latest addition
in that pride we could two of the
females that's hardly Cubs March alia
one that has tuned and I don't believe
that has one dose f3 and then the latest
calves you've seen our of a female
committee who got four so we took you of
seven clubs of course with a different
big difference of age and now that makes
seven we do not know how many caps kinky
got and if maybe she's going to get
three we believe we'll have ten calves
that pride our 10 Cubs from five females
that make fifteen and the two boys that
keep roaming in that particular area for
the territory that have got owned on
your pipe Wow
that Fried she would be growing and to
becoming very big the Mara triangle has
so many plays of lions the largest
currently is could all all all always
very close to our camp but have always
loved the sausages because of how they
behave so those cabs we can't wait and
I'm trying to remember
giraffe go how are you and I'm surprised
to hear and very nice to hear your name
drop guard yes I said roughly
because giraffe gotta tell you I've been
looking for Lions I'll be looking for
the subtree pride and I dropped believe
look carefully you can see the size of
the grass this is so tall and for that
reason I decided I'm going to change and
forget the Lions for some time and look
for jobs you are absolutely correct I
spoke of a job so change clothes don't
go anywhere
if it's not me Tristan James or Jamie we
most likely you will get
and advantage over drove I need about
two three kilometres from why'm I don't
even need to use my father because my
binoculars is too spoiled rough I should
be able to spot one minute drop God
speak of the devil
giraffe god I hope you're still there
let's see whether I spoke too soon oh
let's see what I'm seeing giraffe God
stay right there don't go away this guy
should stop moving
alrighty giraffe
go see speak of the devil
I think I mean the fender controls is
well done and I think it's also well
done - giraffe girl because giraffe God
there you are and that looks like a big
boy just walking across the Savannah and
knowing how toe drops are giraffe girl I
request you don't give me so much
pressure because you know you have a
good friend and stick to the giraffe for
the moment but I like getting pressure
giraffe girl in my life so if you happy
with giraffes I'm equally happy and then
it makes my life easier when we think of
traffic charge elephants I mean lions
and I don't know Deducer 3 I will make a
nice a giraffe golly we can count we
might see four in that particular hard
we could lose to giraffe car let's walk
in there but looking behind them
carefully as much as the grass is pretty
high there are two more well draft God's
good to give us pressure because we
always tell you you know let us know
what you'd like to see and we'll try and
look for it so I said rough girl you're
the one lucky one that's at least for
today this girl I guess this is my very
first animal for the last 45 minutes
pictures have been looking for sausages
lions so suggest lions and I think Saul
is very good travel to change see how
tall the grass is that is the red
autographs which as you see the giraffes
marching through it there
the
not both add or rather put it this way
they are not interested in it because
giraffes browse us and they'll only eat
very small leaves very small trees from
the trees and anytime we see them
bending down like weather yarn they'll
not be eating grass but some although
Hobbes or creepers that will be growing
you know on the ground but these are
classic examples of browsers browsers
hobby was that will only eat leaves or
spawned or bushes and not do that with
the grass this is Masai giraffe this
particular giraffes don't care about you
know the grass how mean the grass looks
pretty green to me it's I would say very
nutritious from the look but giraffes
baying browsers definitely their
destination is to look for a smaller
bush that could have some leaves and
there's a little ego there not sure that
the black just a snake he goes that's my
guess and the giraffe just passed it on
that tortured tree I can only see the
white breast from a distance and my
guess is either blocked I mean the black
chested snake here you see the size of
the grass as Bromley is showing you
there this grass will have to wait until
the wildebeest come near imagine this to
me would be a lot of food for these
giraffes but they are not bothered yes
so cam 3 the one in the front and those
two at the back and I was saying ideas
you can imagine how tall this grass is
this is almost getting to the belly of
this giraffe and no injury also equally
tall you know 6 feet more or less on the
feet you can tell that this crush is
quite high and of course it's benefited
yes I agree with you and this is very
ticklish because even for us when we
walk in this grass you say they're
little ticklish or extend up you know
scratching ourselves because the pollen
but as you say I think the bellies of
this happy words are quite sensitive and
definitely quite ticklish and I'm
guessing that one is at
keep moving keep moving and I would
highly doubt the wild dogs Jimmy Hoffa
would be seen walking through this grass
well done GG for finding a giraffe this
afternoon we have not moved in the
slightest and this is this is pretty
much standard for a muggy afternoon like
this afternoon we've got a hope that
they stay this way right up until hot by
6:00
I mean a bit of movements fine if they
want to come out into the open maybe go
have a drink that'd be great cuz of
course then all of you get to enjoy them
properly as well this is exactly what
happened when BK went out on his first
drive with me and it was don't think was
his first time seeing wild dogs but it
was his first time properly seeing them
and I told him I'm sure some of you
remembered was the Hamiltons pack not
far from where we are now
and I told him that wild dogs can get up
and race off at any minute and they
spent the next hour curled up in little
fluff balls not going anywhere and I
think he was starting to think that I
was completely loopy
he smiled dogs are very snooty
Jase wants to know if male dogs will
leave the pack to start their own when
there are mature the interesting thing
about wild dogs is that it's typically
the females that actually disperse so
usually within most mammals it's the
males you know if you dream our most
mental predators it's the male's that
disperse so typically a young male
leopard will move off in search of
territory and the females and the
females daughters will stick around the
same area and the same goes for lions
prides are the guardians of an area and
the guardians of the genetics ice and
then the males will once they reach
about three years old move off and
establish themselves elsewhere but with
dogs that doesn't exactly work like that
that doesn't mean that males never
disperse or never break away but
typically females will actually move off
into in search of new mating
opportunities and that makes sense
because their biological drive is to
breed and the alpha female typically
doesn't allow a beat of female anything
like or any of the other females below
her to raise a set of Cubs so pups what
is wrong with me I've been thinking
about hyenas I think clearly she will
she typically doesn't allow another
female to raise a set of pups she often
kills them it does happen but it makes
sense then of the females it's not like
with lions where Cubs from every female
are welcomed with open arms and with an
open milk bar as well and they're a low
suckle each other's little Cubs with the
alpha female she tends to guard that
privilege quite jealously so it makes
sense for the females to move off and to
disperse listen here fly sorry goodbye
that was the last straw trying to climb
into my ear was not acceptable tiny tiny
little flies it's a horrible feeling
when they get in there
right is thoroughly thoroughly
captivating as these wild dogs are right
now if you go across to James before his
warthog runs away we have got a water
Pig everybody there it is as you can see
as if we a brief sighting because it is
well not a water Pig born of enormous
bravery disappeared into some thick bush
along with its babies we have found
nothing I'm afraid I did go for walk to
an area where tristin said he had
squirrels alarm calling yesterday and he
watched a hyena walk in there you didn't
have time to go in we found absolutely
nothing I gave it a thorough walk around
over the pig is back little spotted
David and so no luck on that front we're
now on the eastern boundary we're gonna
squizz around here for a while see what
we can find well done a wart piglet a
small water Pig let me the rest
slightly thank you for clicking so that
I knew you were coming back to me
they really are not particularly
forthcoming matter o fact you say
birthday pig for horse Anna well I mean
if you're the pig gonna be very
unfortunate but yes I suppose if you
horse Anna a little bit of pork would be
a good idea and I said what pig is a
delicious meat if you've ever had it now
there is a water buck otherwise known as
an aqua buck that was started by Kirsten
McClaren Smith in the directing chair
and for a long time David Guiteau
thought that we called water buck down
here in South Africa aqua bucks so he
would come across them and say ah some
aqua buck and till a few months later I
said you know I think the jokes wearing
a bit thin he said what joke I said you
know the aqua buck joke and he said what
aqua back joke he didn't know the air
here is now filled with the scent of
smoky leather which is the smell of
water buck I quite enjoy the smell
actually it's quite comforting it's a
little bit like a sniffing a glass of
Laphroaig
apparently the wild dogs in our wake and
they're brought an hour and a half from
walking into chitwa chitwa thinking ok
well that one's asleep but the rest of
the pack are awake I don't want to talk
over this sounds verges listen
definitely hands-down one of my favorite
favorite sounds I haven't moved yet
because yes please yes good good puppies
good puppies that's right
East East little puppies they're so
excited all of a sudden it's amazing how
they go from completely dead asleep to
squeak squeak squeak we're wide awake
mom and dad everybody up everybody up Oh
a tissue are you voting are you voting
whether or not to go hunting I'm sorry I
know I shouldn't joke about a very
serious scientific article but it's uh
it's an article that app it appeared a
couple of years ago I think about two
years ago now about wild dogs voting as
to whether or not they go hunting by
sneezing it has been met with a degree
of skepticism by certain parties I'm
just gonna go I'm gonna move around
might as well move change our position
anyway they're also not going anywhere
but let's see I don't know we are east
east you don't want to go running into
the Sun it's bright go go the other way
then you'll be able to see what's out
there
yes your beautiful thing no no sneezing
no sneezing now only starts to sneeze at
ha plus 6 no that's West
that's West okey-dokey
hold on folks we gonna move
I just want to be in a position to be
able to move if and when I need to o
sleep in the shade that's marvelous I
[Music]
think hopefully that was just a toilet a
brief toilet toilet break
Cantrell said that while dogs very
Street like they've got West Side Story
vibes going on yeah I could see it
they're sleek they fit I can definitely
see the the West Side Story
esque aspects to their nature you expect
them to break into a song and dance
across certainly non rooftops but yes
they do they they click but probably not
while we're watching them and we his
perhaps we should name one Maria hmm are
we back to sleep listen doggies where we
were was quite nice cuz it was they were
shade for us to just just gonna put that
out there you know if you wanted to go
back there that would be okay
temporarily for we are now feeling the
full force of the blazing February
sunlight these dogs are not going back
to sleep I don't think they're listening
across to the wolf there it is whenever
I look at a shot like that I immediately
think of Rite of Spring mr. Pinsky the
Fantastic Fantasia scene with the
dinosaurs our event wants to know moving
on from Stravinsky in the Rite of Spring
whether or not the or how many wild dogs
there are on this pack is eight if this
is the pack I'm thinking of there's one
female three adult males and then four
pups four little pups well they're not
so little anymore they're almost
indistinguishable from the adults that
the Ambala pack has eight members I
don't know which one is the alpha male
yet we know we should obviously there's
only one female therefore she is the
Alpha
all right well that was truly impressive
but while we wait for the wild dogs they
have to get up and start hunting James
has a horn ball that has already been
successful some action there yes it's
there David death a hot imbue it has
caught itself a caterpillar and as a
result of Judy H and James Richard's
explanation of a moth we saw on this
very car the other day I believe that
that is one of the hawk moths that we
saw there that we saw the other day I
believe that is the caterpillar of that
very month and I was just trying to look
it up again but I haven't fortunately
forgotten what the thing was called con
volvulus there we go con volvulus moth
I'm a little small yeah I know that
because my mother grows convolved uses
flowers I couldn't tell you what they
look like but don't that's what she does
and they're fat and green so I think
that may well have been what that was
we're driving up the eastern boundary
hoping to see some tracks of something
coming in and otherwise I don't really
know also apparently the welding on the
antenna at the back is about to come off
which is a little disconcerting so if
you hear the following that means it's
come off and fallen on David's head
we so nice to just find Tandy or
Tenggara draped across one of these
beautiful marula branches
yes indeed Lauren they are called
convolvulus moths because that is one
part of their diet they do eat other
things there are obviously a number of
different species that look quite
similar but that one was called the
convolve Ulis Moffitt involved unis op
Maat
there you are James and Judy I hope you
are impressed that the I remembered one
name it's better than I normally manage
iving very slowly now it wasn't too far
from here that Tandy and ting Ghana were
the other day grumpy old man no duct
tape has not been used the antenna but
cable ties have of course it is a
well-known fact that a wild earth the
company in its entirety would cease to
function without cable ties and gaffer
tape without those two things you
wouldn't have a show
you might think it all has to do with
technology sophisticated broadcast
technology incredible tracking skills
and wonderful Land Rovers but now it
doesn't it has to do almost entirely
with gaffer tape and cable ties
really not much going on here at all I
think or drive a little bit faster and
perhaps head up to peoples of waterhole
all right David unfortunately is not yet
found the sausage tree pride but we'll
see if it's getting closer
very good James now I told you alia the
time is when you get frustrated by one
particular anymore
you forget it and you look for something
else and I decided let me forget my
lions this is the cheap ride for some
time I look for something else and then
I go drops and I am not 100% sure I'll
only request we hold our fingers or we
cross our fingers like this because I
might be seeing something even more
interesting that Jimmy and James will be
very jealous about so it might take me
another two or three minutes together
but a friend of mine has told me there
could be some spotted somewhere I mean
let me show them can get an idea we see
over so many spotted cats here in Kenya
in the mono triangle but this one that
we really see so I want you to tell me
which one you think it is before we get
there so keep guessing and I'm sure
we'll have an idea of what these cuts is
just give me an idea and I'll give you
about 30 seconds to tell me what I'm
talking about
he's a cat we've seen them we've seen it
before but tell me what could I be
talking about is the cat I saw at the
beginning of the year and I switch
another one week ago and we might be
seeing it in the next 10 seconds what do
you think I'm talking about let's find
out so what I got in 1 2 3
let's check out pretty close pretty
closely check out pretty close but it's
related to Chichen Itza god
very good nature God just hang on for
minutes let's check out and I'm gonna
give you an angle that's Bungay I'm
gonna tell me do I keep going you look
good
alright nature girl you're so close a
club for you let you go but now in
counting one two three four five look at
that
I have no words I'm so happy because we
have spotted a lip idea
oh we could leopards in tomorrow we
rarely see them but when we see them
it's always a big day and I mean the
final control says that is awesome and
truly too easy
and I'm trying to look at ah let me cut
it half for now but I'm equals I might
call it more him than hard because by
the size of the head I think it is a
male leopard not very sure I'm sure I
might be getting confirmation from all
the viewers who love this particular
lipid and I'm guessing this could be the
shift tree may leopard I'll put it there
I could be wrong but this could be the
chef wadis tree mail Leopard anybody's
how awesome start I first saw it at the
bit of the yeah oh yeah do you see her
son is a long way and I can tell you a
via this gentleman here by any standard
he is being look at him in any formal
ship you look at him he is a big boy and
I might consider I might compare him to
ting Ghana I do not know and I'm sure M
is going to tell Jamie and Jen interests
and what do you think but from your
screen that M yeah thank you very much
Boone gay for me
this is a male leopard and I'm more
convinced than ever before because of
the julep that he got
yes yes yes I think I would agree with
you I'm the friend of control because
the two main characters outside main
characters because the very unique male
airports in Duma who Komori aunt in
Ghana and any small he's more humor and
I would agree with you that shape of
head and the color of the eyes to be
your eyes they're more of marine so one
thing I cannot tell you one percent this
is a male and I'm almost being convinced
it could be the chef at three may
Leopard how are you sir
now if you look below the neck you can
see the julep I'm talking about and it's
very conspicuous in the mills
unlike the females so definitely I'm now
convinced is a male and I want to lean
to the chef and try lepida now you can
see the chin spots that have always been
used to identify this leopards and
that's one thing we haven't done here in
Kenya and hopefully maybe one day we'll
be able to do that but knowing the
territory he is in I can tell for a fact
this ah is that true chef and because
this is where I saw him I guess a week
ago so this must be the chef at you
leopard Vicki thank you very much great
comment he is massive and Vicki he is
very good-looking and just staying on
top of that salmon mound or Aveo he got
you can see the heartbeat all those
blood vessels under his neck look at
that dude up there and yeah he's either
cuckoo Maury or chin Ghana but I'd say
he is more similar to hook worried in
terms of size and everything else the
size of the head the shape of the head
so we always say leopards got rosettes
Gemma how are you today and all those
jolly to hear your name he is a big boy
I have no idea how old this boy is but
from the face to me it could be like
like
Clee over nine maybe going to ten he
looks pretty tired bill he is an odd boy
Gemma I was looking his nose is he Gemma
we have always thought of young leopards
like husana for example to a lumber for
example their noses owl is a bit pinkish
and that would also happen to lions now
he is so sleepy are you sleeping at
Harley because of your age cause Gemma
Gemma said you're old I don't think so
but yeah if you look at him closely
Gemma you see this no pink on the nose
and baying without a pink my guess is
definitely over six seven so anything
eight nine Wow to be pretty good edge
for him very duck I hate that he got I
could be wrong but I think his ears look
a little short then they no more years
with Stephen leopards but I could be
wrong exactly fitting the description of
who Komori Shefford chilapa do you have
a sneeze like the wild dogs of Jamie or
did he just have a little reflux there
oh you got irritated by a fly
well I'm very excited because for us to
support leopards in tomorrow is always
very special and I'm sure Jimmy as much
as he got wild of shemites feeling wild
and David it promises to be an exciting
exciting but for now it is a very
restful relaxing sighting but well done
GG leopard in the Mara is always a
special special thing that's awesome
news you know it hurts my soul quite a
few times in the Mara when I encountered
a leopard on one of our all-nighters and
had to leave it in favor of whatever
else that we were whatever else we were
following largely because wherever I
found them was areas where we didn't
have signal but it happened non-live
farm off and then it ever happened live
so well done David that's exciting news
I wonder which male it is I'm sure Adam
who works a betting gamma and who's sort
of starting to collate all of the
various moral lipid sightings I'm sure
he'll be very excited to hear that
okay fly goodbye there's one two down to
a fallen victim to my reflexes
NAT would like to know if I think the
wild dogs have eaten since the sighting
this morning or if they are looking
fatter they didn't look particularly
welfare do they don't look that hungry
but I always feel as though wild dogs
have a had a hungry look to them if they
did eat something it was very very small
perhaps to scrub hair obviously I wasn't
out this morning so I didn't see them so
I'm not I don't know exactly what they
look like but if they did it was
probably very little but they've got we
arrived they've got no blood on their
faces they're almost exactly where
Tristan lost them this morning so I
don't think that they've managed to eat
which is why if you're listening wild
dogs you need to go directly to
quarantine at around about half past
6:00 this evening yes yes you just think
you're taking that in you're just a
puppy you don't know what I'm talking
about quarantine by the way for those of
you that don't know you might have
completely misinterpreted that I am not
in any way suggesting these dogs need to
be placed in quarantine it is the name
of an open area on Juma so don't panic
I'm not saying that they're diseased or
anything like that it's just the name of
an open area that's why they must go to
quarantine it occurred to me as I said
it that that would be very confusing for
a new viewer particularly since our new
viewers seem to be quite shy about
asking questions we know you're out
there remember that you can actually
interact with us and you can do that
using the hashtag Safari live on Twitter
alternatively you can send your
questions through on the YouTube chat
stream
all right some South snoozy wild dogs
aren't rushing off anywhere or if you go
across to David's magical Mara and
leopard sighting well hopefully your
wall dogs Jaime will stay until later
tonight as I'm also crossing fingers and
hoping that my male leopard here will
also stay until rather late and I'm so
excited by this leopard and not sure the
M you'd like us to have a bigger cover
much ground with all other online
viewers you know who cross benefit from
this very rare sighting of a male
leopard in the male triangle
hello everyone and a very warm welcome
to the Mara triangle in Kenya and my
name is David and on camera this even is
a bunga bunga how are you and you're
very excited because we've got a very I
sitting here oh lepida not RIA in that
sense we see leopards here in mark
triangle but rather elusive and your own
is rather difficult to see as much as
the scene in Juma or in the Kruger
National Park in South Africa so for us
here in Kenya and most Wyndham our
triangle when it sports a little but we
get very excited well this one number
one it is a meal and I'm saying smell
because of a few reasons the size is
huge he is a big boy too he got a huge
head and in general man has got big
heads and femurs Thank You Bungay I can
adjust a tally of engaged cameraman with
me today and number three if you look
below his neck you can see some piece of
mass hanging there that we call a do
knob so juleps are more general fitting
or the more seen in the males
and like the females now we come into
you life and should you have any
questions and comments please send them
through and how exciting is this we have
some perfect light great temperatures
and we could be doing close to 85
degrees Fahrenheit after about 30
degrees Celsius and look at him he just
pushed and look in a particular
direction and what I think is looking at
awesome impalas from a distance when I
was driving here before I found him I
passed it through some impalas its mojo
herd of impalas and I think that's what
he is trying to focus on if not he could
also be focusing on on maybe something
like a warthog so he is patched up you
know on a salmon mound
lavinda how are you and always a
pleasure to hear your name and you'd
like to know could a leper like this
bring down a buffalo I do not think so
Ravindra I highly doubt but Linda I'm
sure you know merely puts fully grown
ones could be anything 65 70 kilo grafts
and 80 programs maybe the very heaviest
one I have seen some of the leopards
tomorrow bring down prey but it's almost
double your weight w sighs I'm talking
over topi Michael you are asking what
his name is and I'm sure gonna tell you
his name
so ravine de I was just saying earlier
that I've seen leopards that are you
know 70 75 kilograms hundred 450 pounds
bringing down huge prey the sizes of
topi oh-ha twists that are double the
size or double the weight of leopards
but I highly doubt it to bring down a
buffalo but I can tell you ravine down
for a baby Buffalo for a calf it's very
easy for them to bring them down
and apparently ravine de they also
drugged them up the tree now Michael
this leopard here is called the chiffon
tree leopard we have been seeing him
around here
and this Michael is his territory chef a
trainer pod is his name
keep sending through your questions and
comments because via coming to you live
from the Mara Triangle in Kenya Oh Celia
Daniel very good and I'm very happy to
hear your name Daniel again and I'm sure
you remember this this is exactly about
a month ago
because Daniel it was the very first day
of 2019 he is the same man that was
meeting with that particular unknown
female and if Daniel that a female
conceived that day I can tell you in
another two months we might be seeing a
cab old two cups with that particular
female Daniel you are absolutely correct
is the same male that we saw meeting
that day and this is the chef at female
hello sir you're gorgeous you're
good-looking
I was just saying earlier I didn't
finish my thoughts he is patched up
oh he's you know laying down on a
termite mound and atomic mound gives it
an atomic mount gives it a vantage point
to be able to see its surrounding killer
very good you see what an amazing animal
and I'll tell you leopards killer in the
Mara always a bit skittish and we always
tend to see them on top of trees anytime
you see them on the ground they are
always on the move but just to see him
Bakula resting it is just a super
special well ladies and gentlemen I want
to thank you so very much for having
join us for your Christian for your
comments and please keep an eye because
you might be sending you more or less in
the very near future and on behalf of my
cameraman Boone gay and myself David
very many thanks and you can keep
watching us on the youtubes as usual
good bye for now
very good welcome back and my leopards
remains here and as I said the male and
it's called a tree the chef a tree
leopard very luxe very composed and
definitely maybe looking at some food
and thinking where he might be getting
tonight tonight but I won't tell you I
thought I could be the only one winning
and the proud guy or the proud guide in
Kenya but I think James is trying to
catch up with me and maybe a similar
luck that he got well we are having a
bit of luck here with the leopard
Tristan's been looking for it is of
course
I haven't seen her for a long time and I
remember how I nice to see you something
of a relief to say the least
I must say
and a little butterfly there now is she
looking for her mother where is her
mother where's her father that hopefully
Tristan will uncover for us fairly
shortly now when we left her this
morning she was of course on Torchwood
it's not too far from where we are now
where'd quarry pan Bonecrusher Queens
said that she's the most beautiful
leopard well Bonecrusher Queen she might
be I'd also like to know in your opinion
who the ugliest leopard in the world is
not be very careful for answering that
question because you may of course be
attacked a cyber bullied but yes she's
pretty interestingly her nose is already
nearly black it's not that pinkish color
of hosannas it's just slightly sort of
grey pink pink grey greyish pinkish know
what I mean David you don't well mine
suggest you open your eyes and have a
look hmm I do hope she doesn't go far
from here because there are not many
places that she can go from here which
will not result in my breaking this car
so just stay right where you are
tell her our number
I'm now going to have to tell Tristan
about this he's going to be not entirely
pleased sorry I'm I'm gonna have to get
hold of Tristan no I think he's got
tracks actually of a of Tandy stations
we've just bumped into Columba at Quarry
pen
sorry about that Tristan I can just see
steam now coming out of Tristan's ears
he's been making a very big effort to
find her and we've driven along and
bumped but that is the way of the
wilderness I'm afraid Emma says Emma can
see Tristan of course and there is steam
coming out of his ears
beautiful
Linley you say even David found a lipid
um I'll have you know and I still don't
know how this happened
but when David was here with us at Juma
he found he found lipids just about
every time he went out he'd just go out
and say I think I want to find tile
amber today because he can't search our
lumber and lo and behold she would
appear for him he wouldn't track her
she'd just pitch up he'd say the same
about Tandy same story same about all
the lipids and he had a remarkable run
of luck when he was over here so well
while it might be slightly unusual that
he's found a leopard in the Maasai Mara
well he was certainly no slouch over
here
[Music]
david says he's blushing that i would
like to see
so she's just getting herself ready for
TV she will be having her makeup in a
box about half an hour we'll get the
makeup guys through here they'll just
put a bit of dark make a brown two eyes
perhaps and I'm not sure what shoes
they've chosen for her today I think
it's the green stilettos foggy the TV
episodes if you just stay watching until
half past seven you'll get them Shh
you'll also get them without adverts
he's quite hot you can see she's panting
away there I'm tempted to move around to
the other side of her but I'm also
tempted to just stay exactly where we
are and less you know lest the moving of
the vehicle moves her
alright let us go back across to the
leopard man of the Maasai Mara David
Columbus with Hall and the Sun going
down behind his cat
well hopefully Jamie will keep our wall
dogs James will keep two Lamba she's a
nice girl
very cooperative maybe having been
spotted this hour and I might also be
lucky to keep my chef a tree leopard who
knows now the direction he is looking at
for anybody who could be joining us now
I said it is a male and definitely if
you look below the tail you can tell a
hundred percent it is a male apart from
its big size big net big head which
males will have n on the females so the
Russian is looking at is the West and
you can see the color of sunlight there
is that the Sun is going down
not schewe hard the sunset like me and
maybe it was the kiss will be enjoying
the golden moment together see but some
Judy mouths or some saliva coming out
his mouth I'm not sure that's what I saw
something look like a spider web
I'll be looking carefully if she turns
to her left please laughs rather I'll be
able to know what exactly so on well
he's very focused in a particular
direction and I can only think of two
things number one some sort of prey and
the impalas I saw earlier well and very
good very good now that's a very good
job really reminded me that I need to
have all of you I mean the light that we
have look at that sea of grass of the
red or grass the Shefford see leopard
there in the sunset so to all of you may
request for a one-word tweet tell me
what do you think of this sighting one
word tweet
are you sure hashtag safari live on
Twitter so seeing something drooling
there either from his mouth not very
sure it could be when they get to this
particular age that happens a lot yeah
it seems like little silly me kind of
mark so remember one word say tell me
anything would think I mean epic magical
I mean I don't want to tell the watch
have them hashtag safar LaVon Twitter
all this Shefford telepods the gross of
the Savannah
in the Mara triangle and the Sun as it
is setting us we have seen the Sun going
down he is seated very comfortably on a
termite mound and Bungay is trying to
catch him the Savannah or the grass and
the beautiful golden light that is just
coming through look at how beautiful
rosette he got and that's why I may be
way back you know people used to hunt
leopards and they could get the skins
hide either to make coats or shoes or
hearts but luckily that has seems
stopped and we like making our hearts or
shoes or handbags right on a screen like
what you watching now Oh today is quite
old mail maybe nine ish 10 ish years all
there from the leuco his face and the
size but I'd see he's a very prime prime
Errol
what can you see that we can't see is
interesting how these animals are
designed with wonderful visions many
times they see and we look the same
direction they are looking and we see
nothing the next minute we see them
doing stoking doing a chase and catching
something for themselves snuggle well
done golden it couldn't be better than
that thank you for that good comments
now go because I mean if you look on the
sports snag or the results there was
that they're not sports you see there's
a bit of gold in them and the cold again
in the grass and the Golden Sun our Sun
is going down gold and describes the
three very well in one word the rosettes
the grass and the Golden Sun going down
Thank You Bungay for making it so real I
mean it looks to me like a painting
alley gorgeous thank you very much it's
so gorgeous
at the time she look any like one minute
David tell us you and Bungay are not
faking something that is a painting but
thanks for the chef a trilobite for
turning your fish and that will convince
Holly that this definitely is not
painting very very good golden super
good good yes
super good please keep sending your one
wattage hashtag Safari on Twitter can
you can you say Africa exactly I mean
there's no better way of looking at this
but you know it's really Africa and when
you see this you're like wow thank you
Africa and maybe thank you safari life
for what you know will you bring to us
and this is all our magic and how
surprising and how special to see this
how cool it is to see Amelia put in
Savannah very very new area to see lapis
because we'll always see them to Bush
his thicket trees but when I spoke to my
friend he was like you know what I think
is a little put somewhere and from where
I was I definitely knew it must be the
chef at chiller pod and chances are the
male the female axe doesn't live very
far from here is always very skittish I
would say for every ten times these
syllables here is always this boy and
look at that son there see how the trees
there that you call the torture trees
and in the background is the earlier
escarpment and the Sun is trying to push
down and giving us the best colors of
any Sunday evening it's gonna be truly
especial Sunday I initially started
little bit of frustration with the
sausage soup right but now I am sooo so
very happy having seen this Mahler pod
and I don't think he's in a hurry to go
in here I also highly doubt the wild
dogs are going anywhere
I'm definitely not going anywhere
this is thoroughly relaxing waiting for
these wild dogs to get up and move with
the sound of the bush
you know I'm pretty up with uh sort of
the stage lingo and the TV lingo and as
Emma has just pointed out this is what's
known as corpsing no must not course
that's not cause the dogs are stole yeah
they have not moved I'm awake I'm wide
awake I the steering wheel is not
particularly comfortable but I have
experienced far worse than the Mara and
I have actually fallen asleep I once
fell asleep with my forehead against it
sort of with my head resting up against
it like this which was just before Earth
live the actual earth live and I fell
asleep like this because I kept getting
shouted at for moving the car every time
I try to get comfortable and was on the
back end of five all-nighters Olo bear
up always the danger don't you go
falling falling asleep it squeaks big
squeak puppies always go do that behind
the bush oh here comes another one okay
time to move times removed and just like
that we go from a sleepy sighting to up
and moving and I think what's happening
here is that the pups are quite hungry
and they're trying to encourage the
adults of the pack to go off and go
hunting oops
sorry sir be ok didn't land on your foot
you didn't let on your foot I just heard
this thud that I could just imagine of
metal water bottles landing on you ouch
standing by
that's just myself here
I know up and in the open that happens
they're still statically
- I'll keep you updated
sorry guys have to speak over the
squeaking not quite sure I saw the
person who asked me if they could come
in 15 minutes to join us that I may may
not have the dogs in 15 minutes
hey squeaky's they are so gorgeous
aren't they're just the most beautiful
creatures like somebody threw splashes
of paint on them especially the white
why it is always more defined on the
wild dogs the tan and the black sort of
bleeds into each other but the white
stands out
what's the plan puppies I think the
puppies want the adults up and the
adults are not quite ready for this
whole hunting thing to start
fainted wolf says yeah well logit sleep
for now fainted wolf of course has
secured their username that is actually
one of the proposed names of for the
wild dog oh it squeaking growling so a
lot of people believe and a lot of
conservation groups of athletes actually
campaigned for this that the name wild
dog creates a very bad Muskaan ception
that basically what we're dealing with
here is some sort of feral dog which of
course is not the case so it's been
proposed that the wild dog is officially
renamed the painted wolf which i think
is a really lovely name either painted
dog or petted wolf
I think painted wolf works quite well
but then it suggests a much closer
relationship between wild dogs and
wolves then actually exists so maybe
painted dog is a is a better name I'm
not sure it's not for me to decide it
certainly won't be won't hinge on my
narration this afternoon but the painter
definitely has to go in there because
they do look as though somebody's
painted them
are wild dogs have gone back to sleep
and therefore so can i and let's go and
find out whether or not a slumber is
awake yes here we are with the lumber
captain sweet repose see she sleeps on
her back that is the picture of a very
comfortable animal not afraid of
anything
enjoying the sounds of the woodland
Kingfisher the sights indeed of the
Bluebird fire Finch believe it or not
came visiting us recently no it's not
around now David I was just mentioning
what we had seen yes
it's not here right now and a couple of
wax bills a couple of d'oeuvres it's all
just rather peaceful and pretty over
here
I'll try and find your picture this blue
little Jafar Finch our trial probably
succeed mm-hmm blue build or African
fire Finch I think is what we saw yes I
would go with that would you like to see
it david on eq says Shehata fool I think
she's not under full but she's also very
hot it's about 34 degrees today it was
either the Jameson's fire Finch or the
blue binge blue-billed fire Finch in
fact I'm gonna go over the Jameson's
simply because it wasn't as dark on the
back it was much redder all the way
around so Jameson's fire Finch and his
wife a leg no structure AREPO Pereira
leg no structure no Road Oh a Pereira
see I went to the old school there David
I used a book as opposed to an
application on my telephone I will tell
you though that it is pretty warm
sitting where we are in the Sun
Lindsay you said this is a horse our
pose if you've ever seen one know it's
sort of a lipid pose really very quite
like doing that but some oxpeckers
calling as well
but it's just so wonderfully peaceful
let me shut up for 20 seconds and see if
you can pick up the peacefulness of this
scene the tranquility
you know what we have there is a
laughing dove flanked by his honor guard
of to read bulldog splitters very
carefully you can hear the dove quite a
pretty scenery isn't it David
thank you thank you for that David let's
go back across to the Masai Mara where
David got Ambika through I'm sure is
being equally as peaceful as I am ask
him to say peaceful for you well Leopard
usual effort but a female shaman and
maybe would say youngster to a fully
grown male here I'm more convinced now
he's looking at a watch hog I've turned
round a few times and I don't know what
he can see look at him let's just wait
see how he's coming up quietly what do
you see that they can't see my only
guess is this must be a warthog and this
is a very typical posture of a leopard
wanting to hunt I might be a bit soft
of course I'm about 30 meters 40 meters
away from where he is but look at the
intent on his eyes
she is very focused at something now
because of the height of the grass
myself I cannot see top Aranea say wow
that's a great comment I mean it could
be better
Nicholas the rosettes on this particular
Leopard and that's a very slow move it's
very quiet not sure he is still very
interested in what he saw or he just
want to change the position and maybe
concentrate better on what he is seeing
look at the tail and when the tail to me
is up like that he is in business he's
different in your business
auntie that till will go down and is
what I call Horlicks saying again over
but as long as that stair is there is
always a kind of communication between
the tail and the brain or the brain in
the tail because look at how the tail is
act so it's urged in a particular angle
at 90 degrees and either is not given to
some kind of balance but it is
definitely a communication between that
stare and that's brain and a lot of
times as much as we do not know what
lupus are thinking but the tails will
always tell a lot select the color he
got on his body so either whatever it
was it must have been what talked that
could have been disappeared in the grass
and it may be not interested anymore but
either way look in the background there
or the sunset so so very beautiful and
I've always said Africa I don't know
what other places you'd compare to
Africa look at the sunset there and the
trees that you see the background there
vertical the tortured trees very iconic
of the Mara triangle and for those of
you who could be joining us now we got a
male leopard here that you call the chef
at Reed
and he's definitely focused on something
now look at the julep below his neck and
that is one characteristic that will
always give away a male from a female
he's blending in very well in the grass
that you see there
so whatever prey he is looking at I'm
very convinced it cannot see him
initially it was on top of a shaman
Mount Cristo very good Christian Leopard
and cheetahs differences are massive
both of them are cuts number one but
when you look at them in size and
they're different
leopards are much stock here much heavy
stout rebuilds thus number one number
two layer ponds have what we call
rosettes when you look at their bodies
they call rosettes and when you look at
cheetahs they got what we call sports
their behaviors are so very different
lipids getting sleep again
leopards do not chase their prey for too
long they'll always look and he'd go to
the hunting would stock on very short
distances and then they latch all the
pounds on the prey
cheetahs give kisses and I'm sure you
know the first time was enough they
could completely do 100 110 kilometers
per hour running now cheetahs in general
unless you get a coalition of cheetah
see two or three males or maybe a mother
and have fully grown Cubs
cheetahs go for small game and talk
about it Thomson kazars
chronic results or impalas or babies of
neurological ease but leopards have been
known to go for a big bigger males in
general bigger prey in general and
taking for example impalas they have
been known to go for bigger animals than
them like tapas or harvest or even for
zebras in a young young force of zebras
quite a number of differences I am just
keeping a watch our team to find out
what exactly he'll be doing as the Sun
is going down there
and ideally one of the differences
leopards tend to hunt both day and night
whereas cheetahs in general hunt in
during the day but of course there are
few cases where cheetahs will hunt also
at night but it's quite unusual so the
major difference between the two but
looking or sort some commonalities
between the two yeah in general very
solitary leopards live on their own
cheetahs on their own not in big groups
and I just want to sit here as a watch
this leopard no it's watching my golden
moment on the Sun going down let's find
out how active at the wild dogs are our
dogs are up and slowly moving it's not
look at them
oh they're gonna stop now now that's a
very silly branch to want to play with
not quite at full hunting speed yet
still up for distractions like the
branch of a very thorny acacia mmm yummy
that's not at all dangerous I feel like
such a mom but I just want to tell it to
be careful of its eyes here we go we're
up and moving a pups you are going in a
really bad direction I just want to say
yes you do a good boy you're a good boy
well done thank you in those gorgeous
brown eyes deep deep deep in color not
the light-colored eyes of a lipid or
lion that of course a indicative of a
diurnal hunter Amy says that he would
call wild dogs splotchy dogs
I suppose one up on the wild dogs
cousins side it just sounds like a dog
that's broken into paint factory though
and gone rolling around nice big yawn
there showing off those white teeth
yes you're a good doggie I like you
you're looking in the right direction
Tannis wants to know whether or not wild
dogs or hyena have more teeth wild dogs
have more teeth they have 40 teeth which
is typical of the canine or the canid
family because there are with dogs they
tend to have far more teeth than most of
the other predators the animal our Tia
that has the most teeth you won't see
here but you will see in the Mara which
is the bat-eared Fox
but between wild dogs and hyena you're
looking at dogs dogs have more teeth 40
to be exact which is actually less than
most species of dog or most members of
the dog family very sharp sheering
carnassial teeth good dogs
you stay just right there
so one thing about Wild Dogs
particularly for TV shows because all of
you who've been watching for a long time
know how beautiful our but they have a
tendency to be difficult to describe to
TV audiences anyway never mind
or if you go across to Kalama as the Sun
begins its descent
look how artistic David is being on his
Sunday afternoon Columba was stalking
everybody you missed it
she stoked dove for three seconds then
she went back to sleep now she's up
looking around the place pondering the
movement of the waves in the water and
thinking to herself I wonder how it is
that waves work it looks like we have
some reflection and refraction going on
here
and I wonder how that affects them I
don't think she's really thinking that
I think she's thinking where is my next
meal going to come from and I have to do
the shopping myself it's a little bit
like when you're a student and you leave
home for the first time aged 18 full of
confidence that life is easy and you
have all the answers until you make your
way to the supermarket for the very
first time to buy yourself some food and
realize that in fact you can no longer
afford yogurt or butter or meat there's
nice things and you start finding
yourself a bulk discount store buying
blue paper that would best be used to
sand paper and that sort of thing
mayonnaise that it's more akin to paint
stripper than it is at the mayonnaise
you used to at home that sort of thing
and well she's in that stage of life now
where the needs to hold the ability to
eat fresh die-cut Steinbach and Impala
is being replaced by they need to eat
things like stinky Terrapins okay we're
going to go back to David come back at
all for the end of this particular end
of the show we'll see you on TV ha ha
well what a day today to finish you know
or to come to the end with two front
predators you know wild dogs with Jimmy
and myself with the male leopard here
and James with a female or with the
leopard s who I think is the princess of
joema now we can compare these two
leopard because this one is a big boy
and from the edge or from the rough as I
gave him maybe think about you know 910
years he's a fully grown age I mean I'm
very excited as I said earlier we gonna
let us all about Kenya you know and more
tomorrow triangle is it is in Juma but
we see them more in demand than here so
every day we see a leopard is always a
very exciting day I start my drive today
with little bit of frustration looking
for my favorite sauce little pride which
is not see anything but how switch to
see male there was a stir day is ending
well I want to thank all of you for all
your questions for all your comments and
on behalf of my colleagues Tristan Jimmy
James myself and the camera operators
who do a very good job thank you again
and again and hopefully we'll be seeing
you again tomorrow morning and from all
of us thank you and goodbye